quiero armar un puente
muchas veces en hispanoamérica no le
ponemos atención a la tecnología porque
esas cosas de otros y lo que quiero que
entiendan Es que la tecnología es como
aventar una piedrita a un estanque
entonces hay olas y olas y olas y a
veces es una piedrota
y a veces es un meteorito
entonces la gente siente que Uber
es pues una app que puede uno colocar en
el teléfono y llega El cochecito Y ya y
a veces se molesta un taxista
pero lo que quiero que entiendan es una
piedra
porque el impacto que tiene Uber Es que
hace muy sencillo que no tengas coche y
el coche es increíblemente caro porque
tienes que pagar el seguro tienes que
pagar el financiamiento tienes que pagar
el garaje tienes que pagar Pues el
accidente etcétera etcétera
y lo que está empezando a pasar es que
si manejas menos de 16.000 kilómetros
por año no es Sensato si vives en una
ciudad usar un coche particular Y
entonces el 22% de los usuarios de Uber
o de todos los otros servicios
Sencillamente no están comprando
automóviles
Y qué es lo que va a pasar en la
siguiente década Entonces lo siguiente
de acá lo vamos a tener automóviles
autónomos y el automóvil autónomo va a
bajar el costo de usar unos servicios en
50%. y en ese momento no es Sensato
comprar un automóvil particular
Entonces qué es lo que empieza a pasar
en países como Brasil o México o lugares
que tienen grandes empleos armadoras
autopartes Pues que la venta de
automóviles particulares bajan un 80-90%
, Por qué Porque los automóviles
empiezan a usar como los aviones están
en constante circulación
entonces una cantidad muy importante de
empleos puede empezar a cambiar de
manera fundamental por esa piedrita que
va en total
no solamente cambia el negocio de los
Autopartes esto cambia de manera
fundamental las ciudades
pónganse a pensar un edificio de
oficinas típico la cuarta parte la
tercera parte de ese edificio es
estacionamiento
todo estacionamiento empieza a
desaparecer porque llega el automóvil
cuando lo necesites Entonces el costo de
una oficina por metro cuadrado empieza a
bajar el costo de una vivienda por metro
cuadrado empieza a bajar el
estacionamiento en las calles empieza a
desaparecer la velocidad promedio de
circulación una ciudad empieza a subir
entonces hay una serie de cambios
sistémicos
en la principal causa de muerte para
jóvenes entre 16 y 60 años que son los
accidentes automovilísticos hay un
cambio en el negocio de los seguros pues
ya no se van a necesitar seguros para
automóvil hay un cambio en los seguros
de vida porque desaparece una causa
importante de que te mueras Entonces
esta piedrita Resulta ser un meteorito y
lo que es muy peligroso para América
para los hispanos por América Latina es
no entender que una tecnología ortogonal
que parece que no nos afecta nos va a
afectar de manera fundamental Déjenme
darles un segundo ejemplo hace algunos
años fundó una compañía con Craig
bangter y hemsmat que básicamente tomó
todo el código genético de una célula y
lo sustituyó por un código genético
completamente distinto Y eso lo que hace
es permite programar una célula para
ejecutar funciones entonces un poquito
como lo que pasa en mi teléfono pongo
una serie de Apps y este maneja fotos y
este maneja mensajes y este maneja
música y este maneja el otro Eso es lo
que podemos hacer con una célula porque
es tan importante esto porque al poder
programar células podemos programar casi
cualquier cosa que sea orgánica entonces
casi cualquier cosa que se produce de
manera orgánica en fábricas o en Campos
lo podemos hacer ahora en grandes
piletas de sopita verde como esta
entonces aquí podemos fabricar gasolinas
y lo vamos a hacer con nexon en una
gasolina básicamente neutral en uso de
carbono
pero también en una serie de industrias
paralelas esto empieza a cambiar de
manera fundamental Por ejemplo si estás
en el campo agrícola en vez de producir
tres cosechas al año para sacar la
proteína de la soja o el aceite de Palma
o el aceite o el azúcar del maíz pues
ahora lo puedes hacer en celulitas y lo
puedes hacer una vez y otra vez y otra
vez produciendo 10 a 100 veces más por
hectárea de lo que produces con la
agricultura tradicional y lo mismo lo
puedes hacer con ganadería puedes
fabricar hamburguesas de otra manera que
en el 2013 costaban 300 mil dólares hace
dos años costaban 30 dólares y hoy
cuestan tres entonces son cambios
sistémicos que si estás en Argentina si
estás en Brasil si estás en México es
muy importante entender estas pequeñas
cambios en las piletas que generan la
tecnología que se esparcen por toda la
sociedad
comemos entonces un inventario cómo
vamos a enfrentar esto en América Latina
qué es lo que vamos a hacer con Qué
recursos manejamos estas cosas esa fue
una discusión que tuve en Brasil hace
algunos años con miembros del gabinete y
llegué y les dije pues miren yo soy un
pobre mexicano quiero entender de
ustedes que son los maestros cómo lo
hicieron para ganarle a todo el mundo
cinco veces a todo el mundo
claro estoy hablando de fútbol
y bueno no pueden entender la energía
que viene ese salón me llenaron todos
los pizarrones me dijeron lo explicaron
que los mejores entrenadores y que la
Excelencia y la especialización y las
dignidad y el apoyo social y todo esto
Ok mi esposo de 20 minutos dije Oigan y
este en esto de las escuelas primarias y
secundarias
Cuáles de Estos principios
lo siguen al escoger a los maestros y al
escoger a los profesores y al escoger a
los alumnos
los metan mucho dinero les van apoyo
social buscan a los mejores entrenadores
hacen una selección nacional
y cuál es la consecuencia de tratar el
fútbol como una competencia mundial en
fútbol
y que Corea trate a las escuelas como un
deporte de competencia mundial porque en
Corea cuando tomas una prueba al final
de tu preparatoria eso determina si vas
a ir a la universidad aquí universidad
vas a ir y que vas a estudiar y es un
sistema absolutamente brutal sí tiene un
costo altísimo en términos de vidas
personales de toda una serie de cosas
pero también tiene una consecuencia para
el país porque
imagínense que están viendo no Imagínese
están viendo un millón de puntitos
imagínense que son un millón de
ciudadanos Entonces qué es lo que nos
pasa a nosotros que toma Más o menos
726 mil de estos puntitos generar una
patente en Estados Unidos por parte de
los mexicanos y los mexicanos
toma Más o menos 635 mil brasileños toma
237.000 chilenos
toma 56.000 españoles
tomó tres mil coreanos
toma 2000 norteamericanos
y cuando uno tiene un índice de
productividad con estos diferenciales en
términos de creación de conocimientos
porque una sociedad se educa en
tecnología y la otra no
pues acaba viendo una diferencia de 250
veces y qué es lo que acabó pasando en
esta época donde los conocimientos
empiezan a dominar la economía
Pues que la economía de Corea y de
México producían prácticamente lo mismo
hasta los mediados de los 80s y ahí la
educación los conocimientos el general
empresas como cemso en el Corea y no
hacer eso en México o en Brasil o en
Argentina tiene consecuencias de largo
plazo que ahora han llevado a un
diferencial de ingreso de 3.3 veces en
menos de una generación
tomemos una de las grandes universidades
de América Latina la UNAM más vieja que
Harvard la UNAM se jacta de que solo
admite el 8% en un examen nacional pero
cuatro quintos partes de la gente que
entra la UNAM no toma ese examen
nacional no compita a nivel nacional
entra por las escuelas afiliadas a la
UNAM inclusive las carreras de ciencia
y hay gente que dice que debemos de
tener un pase automático
que todo mundo debería poder entrar que
no deberíamos hacer elitistas Ok
apliquemos Esas reglas a las olimpiadas
Qué pasaría si nuestro equipo olímpico
de fútbol o de judo o de veleo de lo que
quieran ustedes la quinta parte entra
por ser los mejores del país y cuatro
quintas partes entran porque los
estudiaron la empresa del entrenador
y pueden entrar con calificación de 10
de 9 de 8 de 7 a una competencia mundial
qué vamos a hacer
pues entramos a la capilla del Santo
Niño del remedio
Esto no es una cosa que tenemos que
hacer a largo plazo podríamos por
ejemplo tomar los campos del teleférico
en Monterrey o de escuelas similares en
otros países y buscar al mejor 2%. a los
que están dos o tres desviaciones de la
media del lado derecho de esta curva y
concentremos esos alumnos en un solo
Campos y pongamoslos a competir como
coreanos durante dos años
si estos alumnos se gradúan con un
diploma del ubertech o del Uber UNAM
vamos a tener dos o tres de las mejores
universidades del mundo
en un periodo muy corto de tiempo en
México o en Brasil y en Argentina porque
vamos a empezar a tratar a lo mejor que
tenemos como una selección nacional
Y por qué importa tanto esto porque en
una época de conocimientos
55 gentes que generaron un WhatsApp
generan el mismo valor de Mercado que
toda la gente que se levantó Durante un
año a trabajar en 15 países a
Centroamérica y el Caribe
imagínense que todos los mañana se
levanta la gente en Honduras todos los
agricultores todos los taxistas todos
los políticos todos los poetas todos
trabajan sus 10 12 horitas diarias y no
generan el mismo valor en el país entero
de lo que generaron 55 gentes que
fundaron WhatsApp
estamos en una época donde podemos
construir economías grandotas con muy
pocas Mentes pero esas mentas tienen que
ser competitivas a nivel mundial y las
tenemos que identificar
y el problema en América Latina es que
obtenemos lo que celebramos Entonces
por ciertamente tenemos a grandes
deportistas Y claro hay uno que otro
político que celebramos
literatos no nos faltan
pero habrá alguna gente en América
Latina que no me puede decir de
inmediato Quiénes son estos tres
que no sabe Quiénes son de ti que no
sabe quién es Molina que no sabe quién
es
este y eso es parte de nuestro problema
porque los tres ganaron la Premier Nobel
en ciencias
los tres deberían ser nuestros Héroes
los tres Debería ser nuestros modelos
Ese es nuestra selección nacional
y atrás de ellos
hay miles y miles de jóvenes que salen
de Michoacán que salen de Oaxaca que
salen de Paraná que salen de todas las
partes más Humildes América del Norte
tiene compiten a nivel mundial en
Harvard
y no los conocemos y no lo celebramos
entonces la idea que quiero
transmitirles es que hay que entender y
celebrar la ciencia y la tecnología y la
educación
y sobre todo hay que celebrar la
selección nacional de cerebros
Muchísimas gracias